قالت اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي ان الجيش
اقترب من التوصل لتفاهمات مع مصر بشان
محور فيلادلفيا واضافت ان التفاهمات
الوشيكه مع مصر تشمل عدم القيام بعمل
عسكري في رفح حتى يتم اجلاء سكانها باتجاه
الشمال لمنع نزوحهم الى مصر وحسب اذاعه
الجيش الاسرائيلي سيتم بموجب التفاهمات
انشاء جدار باحدث التقنيات تحت الارض
بتمويل من دوله عربيه لمنع وجود او وجود
اسرائيل على
المحور من القاهره معنا السفير حسين هريدي
مساعد وزير الخارجيه المصري السابق سيد
السفير حسين ما تعليقك على ما ورد في هذا
الخبر من تاكيد من قبل الجانب الاسرائيلي
بما يتعلق بوجود اتفاق مع الجانب المصري
فيما يتعلق بمحور فيلادلفيا
مساء
الخير ننتظر طبعا ننتظر
حضرتك تصريح رسمي من القياده العامه
للقوات المسلحه المصريه في هذا الشان دوت
اذا كان في اتفاق كما جاء في وسائل
الاعلام
الاسرائيليه ما نستطيع ما استطيع ان اقوله
الان حضرتك انه محور فيلادلفيا ده جزء من
المنطقه دال والمنطقه
دال هي حسب بروتوكول البروتوكول الامني
الملحق بمعاهده السلام بين مصر واسرائيل
بيحدد حضرتك عدد
الافراد المتواجده في هذه المنطقه
ومبر ممر محور صلاح الدين بيقع حضرتك في
المنطقه
دال وكما تعلم حضرتك والساده المشاهدين
الكرام ان هذا المحور هو شريط حدودي يربط
بين مصر وغزه يمتد من البحر المتوسط غربا
وحتى المعبر الاسرائيلي لكرم ابو سالم
شرقا لمسافه 14 كيلو ونص وهو بالتالي
عندما تم التوقيع على معاده السلام
المصريه الاسرائيليه في مارس
79 كان قطاع غزه تحت الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
وبالتالي هذا الشريط الحدودي دخل في نطاق
البروتوكول
الدفاع الملحق
بالمعاهده المذكوره في هذا الماده اثنين
من بروتوكول الدفاع بتحدد حضرتك عدد
القوات الاسرائيليه اللي تتواجد في
المنطقه دال
ا لا تزيد عن اربع كتائب مشاه وان عدد
الافراد الكتائب المشاه لا يتجاوز 4000 ا
جندي وغير مسرح بوجود دبابات غير مسرح
بوجود مدفعيه غير مسرح بوجود صواريخ مضاده
للطائرات الا الصواريخ المحموله على الكتف
للجنود
ويتواجد في هذه
المنطقه عدد 180 عربيه نقل جند مدرعه وليس
اكثر من هذا وبالتالي كل هذا بينطبق حضرتك
على محور فيلادلفيا ده ما استطيع ان اقول
ال سي السفير ما ذكرته الان في انتظار كما
ذكرت بيان رسمي من القوات المسلحه المصريه
يرجح امكانيه حدوث اتفاق وفق صيغه ما ام
يستبعدها بناء على ما ذكرت الان من
معطيات حضرتك وفقا لمعاهده السلام المصريه
الاسرائيليه في مكتب اتصال مصري وفي مكتب
اتصال
اسرائيلي مكتب الاتصال الاسرائيلي بير سبع
ومكتب الاتصال المصري في العريش والتنسيق
بين البلدين بيتم حول الترتيبات الامنيه
كما جاءت في معاهده السلام وملحق الملحق
الامني حضرتك بيتم عبر هذين المكتبين اي
تحركات سواء من جانب مصر او من جانب
اسرائيل في المنطقه ا والمنطقه ب والمنطقه
ج والمنطقه د اي تحرك قات حضرتك خارج ما
اتفق عليه بيتم التشاور المسبق بشانها
ا عندما ترددت انباء وعندما صرح رئيس
الحكومه الاسرائيليه ووزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي انه العمليات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه هتمت لمحور فيلادلفيا لا شك
ان مصر اعربت عن معارضتها التامه لمثل ذلك
لانها تعلم ان وجود قوات اسرائيليه في
محور فيلادلفيا ا خارج الاعداد التي ورد
ذكرها في ملحق الدفاع ده يعتبر انتهاكا
لمعاهده السلام المصريه الاسرائيليه ا بعد
هذا الموقف المصري كان في اتصالات ماذا
اسفرت عنه الاتصالات دوت ننتظر حضرتك او
انا على الاقل لن اعلق انا هنتظر بيان
رسمي من القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه
المصريه